the [ __ ] Hello sir nails good morning
how are you What did you eat for
breakfast this morning sir the menu is in
Indonesia How did you go to
school today sir Oh the gear
went by motor vehicle
but today I use a car
so this is different, sir, when you are on a motorbike with
the car continues, sir, number three,
how long does it take to travel from home to
school, from where I
stay, it's about
minutes after hours, yes, from
my house in the village in the village, it's
about maybe three and a half
How is it, sir, wow continues  Sir, the fourth question,
what was your mindset when you entered
school, what was your mindset when I entered
school, what I thought
about was how to make the
children happy. For the children, the man brought
Granger Facebook, only one thing, Sir, what do
you like at your school?
that room I really like the class
yes the room Must be very trying is a
place that definitely likes no  watch the movie Who is
Pakpuh's favorite movie star at home
and abroad If Bisma is a
film that is in the country I like to
forget to be on a route abroad
outside of Indonesia I like Mejiksen,
his acting is really good,
hi, okay, continue with number7.wap, let's make a movie
now  Favorite singer or band,
Pak Kukuh Bajaj Indonesia, I like to
make sure that in your life you
have a hero who is marked
as a true idol. Who is that, sir, when you're
done, if he has the passion to
fight against oppression?
I really want
to go to Switzerland so uh switch the
iceberg try the Alps connection maybe in
Papua Indonesia Very good okay I
want to know this is my favorite lesson when
teaching at school it
smells when I am healthy in high
school I really like
history lessons but if I teach something different
i like science and also censor
math students what kind of
android s  That school Oh I'm a student at
school that was a bit clumsy,
clear I used to be the class president Wow class
and I was always the leader at that
time, the class president knew
even though I wasn't very popular
So if Pak Kukuh was having a snack at
school in the school canteen
what's your favorite sir
hi oh if you go to school I usually
eat soto soto if it's in soto maybe
tomorrow, the sub is fresh rice, it's definitely
warm, sir, it's warm, number 14 is standard,
what time do you usually leave
school?
For example, if
there is an additional 6th grade lesson, it can be
up to 4.16 at five Egypt Do you
usually still work when you go home
Hi I really like that there is still a lot
of work at home so it's a shame to
have to work until the evening
make sure you're at work if you
're bored you need to relax  Usually,
you do nothing. When you
relax, I usually always do what I call
it, because I'm lying down
take a break to drink warm milk and also watch
some entertaining
music. Lahat auto the film is very
steline teaching
Hi, what is your hobby or interest, sir
Kukuh Oh yes
, I really like sports, futsal is like that I really like it so I
believe it But it should be digital
what's your proudest achievement
as a teacher so much my achievement
is in terms of winning champions
from the Constitutional Court being a pet
I'm happy when my students become
smart it's also a great achievement
If you could write one
motivational quote on the blackboard ahead would it
Hi maybe not  I wrote yes but
I like the deposit, namely hops Gitu ergosum
I think I have eyes So
today I have to think about what
and how what is the most important advice
you give to your students
[Music]
My advice to make students
smart is important but more  it's important to
be a good person in the end
Why are you Mr. Teguh  being a
teacher being a teacher
[Music]
is a
call from the soul, so you have to have
passion, there is a strong desire and that's what
I experienced when I worshiped and felt like it was
my choice
[Music]